1930 and in spain things are getting a
bit tense
it was at this point led by king alfonso
the 13th and his prime minister slash
dictator general miguel primo de rivera
rivera was hugely unpopular and had
cracked down on many democratic
opponents and he'd also alienated the
army which led to his resignation in
january he was replaced by general
damaso beringuer who continued the
dictatorship but spaniards named it
dictablanda or the soft dictatorship
opposition to the dictatorship and the
monarch who maintained it continued to
grow during 1930 and to the outbreak of
an uprising in kaka here this uprising
was crushed and alfonso chose to replace
beringway in 1931 with admiral juan
batista athnad who called for local
elections
the opposition known as republicans won
and went one step further by declaring
spain a democratic republic and alfonso
who couldn't count on the military for
support simply left
this ushered in the period of the second
spanish republic which incidentally was
one of the few nations to have the
colour purple on its flag
a new provisional government led by
niseto asalathamoda was established and
quickly began to implement reforms
in june 1931 an election was held to
elect men for a constitutional cortes
which would draft the new spanish
constitution
this constitution included things such
as freedom of speech and assembly as
well as the separation of church and
state
it also importantly placed the church's
money under the control of the
government and prevented religious
orders from teaching in state schools
this upset many of the deeply catholic
population and led to assalathamoda
himself a very religious man resigning
his position of prime minister in
october he wasn't jobless for long
however since he was elected to the
mostly ceremonial role of president by
the constitutional cortes in november
his replacement as prime minister was a
man called manuela sanyo who was a
left-wing republican and wanted to push
through major reforms
you may have noticed that neither of
these two were elected in general
elections and in fact the constitutional
cortes continued to govern the nation
well after the constitution was finished
not very democratic
athanya continued to bring in reforms
such as expanding the franchise to women
in 1933 and redistributing land from the
rich to the poor
further reforms included granting
greater local autonomy to catalonia in
the basque country and shrinking the
size of the army
athanya struggled to keep public ordered
though and after some revolts which were
quickly crushed it became clear that the
spanish people no longer wanted him in
charge and so elections were called in
1933.
ethanya lost and was replaced by a
right-winger called alejandro leroux who
sought to reverse many of the previous
reforms
larue struggled to govern effectively
when it became clear that his government
would be a very conservative one the
socialist demanded a general strike to
bring the country to a halt
this led to the astorias rising which
saw armed socialist caesar viedo in
october of 1934.
the army put this revolt down and so
left-wing parties realized that they
needed to cooperate if they were to
regain power and so together formed the
popular front in 1936.
larue's government collapsed due to a
financial scandal and elections were
called which saw the popular front led
by ethanya wynn athanya soon after
ousted our salah the murder as president
and took his place but his presidency
was tarnished by local violence between
left and right wing groups
the most notable of these right-wing
groups was the phalange which was
modeled on the fascist parties of europe
and whose leader jose antonio had been
arrested
the breakdown of civil order and the
promises of greater autonomy to the
regions worried many in the army who
thought that the country would
disintegrate led by general muller much
of the army planned to ask the
government to stop this
both sides started assassinating members
of the other and the most notable of
these was the murder of jose calvo
cetello the leader of the monarchist
party
this left basically no notable
right-wing leaders and so the army
decided now that this was the time for a
coup to begin the elite african army
began a revolt in spanish morocco on
july the 17th
1936 seizing it and they were soon after
joined by their leader a certain
francisco franco
the expectation was that the republican
government would surrender
it didn't instead the new prime minister
jose gerald issued weapons to unions and
workers to fight the army
the rebels had the advantage of the
support of most of the army whereas the
republicans had the navy on side as well
as the industry and resources of most of
spain by the end of august though the
front lines look like this with the
rebels now calling themselves the
nationalists controlling about a third
of the country
in october the nationalists proclaimed
general franco as the head of state
because all of the other leaders like
moller had died
since the arrested jose antonio of the
phalange party had been executed franco
placed himself as its new leader
so both the nationalists and the
republicans had their foreign backers in
the civil war the nationalists were
supported by portugal italy and germany
whereas the republicans were given aid
by the soviet union mexico into a much
lesser unofficial extent
france so by april 1937 spain looked
like this and it was in this month that
one of the most famous events of the
civil war occurred the bombing of
guernica by the german volunteers the
condole legion this bombing devastated
the city killing five percent of its
population in one day this wasn't the
only atrocity of the war though both
sides massacred civilians and prisoners
and the nationalists operated
concentration camps and used forced
labour
the nationalists were able to conquer
the north of the country taking most of
catalonia by the end of 1938.
it was here incidentally that george
orwell fought and became disillusioned
with communism and with bullets since he
got shot in the throat
one of the reasons that the republican
side struggled was that it contained
many diverse political groups such as
communists socialist liberals and
anarchists
these factions often bickered and
sometimes attacked one another meaning
unity was all but impossible since they
had different end goals
in february 1939 the nationalists
conquered barcelona and britain and
france recognized franco as the spanish
head of state
the next month saw the fall of madrid
and the republican leadership flee
on april the 1st franco announced an end
to the civil war in a nationalist
victory
franco now had the job of securing his
power and rebuilding the country
spain was formally declared a one-party
state with franco as its leader franco
is often described as a fascist and in
many ways this is both right and wrong
since he and his regime defy
categorization he did use force to
repress dissent and the independence
movements of catalonia in the basque
country and he put the needs of the
regime above those of the population
however he did respect private property
and made little effort to police
people's private thoughts and actions
people were free to leave spain many
positions in government were appointed
on merit and some criticism was
tolerated so the regime could adapt
so almost immediately after the civil
war was over a little-known event called
world war ii kicked off
franco kept spain out of the war despite
close ties to germany and italy mainly
because spain was still a smoldering
wreck and wouldn't have been able to do
much anyway
this doesn't mean that franco completely
ruled it out though hitler wanted to
move his troops through spain to capture
gibraltar but franco's demands were too
high
the price of spanish help was
forgiveness for spain's debts and franco
also wanted germany to provide most of
the equipment
franco's demands angered hitler who even
threatened to give catalonia to vichy
france but in the end
nothing happened spain did however
contribute some volunteers to the war
but after 1942
started to shift towards a passive
support for the allies after world war
ii was over spain was internationally
isolated since it didn't pick a side
it was also suffering from a sluggish
economy which mostly came about as a
result of franco's economic policy
called ortarki
this was where spain intentionally
played very little role in international
trade and sought to be entirely
self-sufficient
this didn't go very well and in the
1950s the regime had to implement major
economic reforms which aimed at bringing
in foreign investors
this included allowing for u.s military
bases and placing emphasis on industrial
development instead of promoting
agriculture as it had done previously
spain still held the remnants of its
once great empire and in 1956 morocco
gained its independence from france
as a result of this franco ceded spanish
morocco to muhammad the fifth its new
king but kept the territories of sayutra
malia muhammad v wanted these as well as
ifny here and so in 1957 invaded
long story short the spanish with the
help of the french one militarily but in
the peace negotiations decided to give
morocco this territory the decade
following the ifny war was a pretty good
one for spain
the country opened up and the economy
boomed a large portion of which came
from the growing tourism industry press
censorship was relaxed and franco turned
a blind eye towards the growing
underground political parties which
opposed him
a lot of these changes were due to spain
wanting to join the international
community and open up trade with its
european neighbours
most of these organizations such as nato
and the european economic community said
no but spain was admitted to the united
nations in 1955.
hereafter the remnants of the spanish
empire were given up with ifny being
seeded to morocco in 1968 an equatorial
guinea being given independence the next
year
one territorial matter that was not
resolved though was that of gibraltar
franco had made many diplomatic efforts
aimed at regaining gibraltar for spain
but all of them were rebuked which led
to him closing the border with it in
1969 so by the late 1960s franca was
getting a bit old and so measures had to
be taken to prepare for his death and
succession
in 1947 franco had promised to restore
the monarchy he began making true on
that when in 1969 he appointed prince
juan carlos of the house of bourbon
as his successor incidentally franco had
first asked the habsburgs to take the
throne but they declined because at this
point a habsburg hadn't ruled spain
since the 18th century
in 1973 franco appointed admiral carrera
blanca was the president of the council
of ministers basically the prime
minister
this was a time of growing unrest as
workers demanded greater rights to go
with their increased economic freedom
the economy began to slow down again and
even the church began backing social
change and opposition groups
the late 60s and early 70s also saw the
beginnings of ita a basque terrorist
organization who were responsible for
many bombings and political
assassinations
the most notable of these occurred in
december 1973 when ita managed to blob
admiral blanco on his way to mass
blacker was replaced by carlos arias
navarro who struggled to maintain
order in 1975 after suffering from
repeated bouts of illness for many years
franco died and was succeeded by the
prince who became king juan carlos the
first
juan carlos immediately began to lay the
foundation for a transition away from
dictatorship to democracy
he asked darius navarro to resign and
appointed a man called adolfo suarez as
his replacement juan carlos and suarez
had both promised to uphold the
francoise constitution and maintain the
dictatorship
fun fact no they began to work behind
the scenes to pressure francois
politicians to dissolve the parliament
to begin democratic elections
the king lifted the ban on opposition
political parties even the communist
party in 1977.
in june of the same year there was an
election which women could vote in and
suarez's party the ucd won with the
socialist coalition coming second
in 1978 a new constitution was written
enshrining civil liberties and granting
regional autonomy to both catalonia in
the basque country
after this barring a failed coup in 1981
spanish democracy remained strong and it
was welcomed back into the international
community
spain's period of authoritarianism had
come to an end and the work of juan
carlos the first in this is hard to
overstate
he and suarez had resisted immense
internal pressures and stunned
international onlookers by quickly and
peacefully dismantling the francois
system and ushering in a new age for
spain
i hope you enjoyed this episode and
thank you for watching there are some
book recommendations in the description
below if you'd like to know more